the Democrats climate change scam just
got a huge reality check from one of the
world's richest men the Al Gore's and
the aocs of the world love to exaggerate
the effects of global warming constantly
warning us how boiling oceans are going
to Doom Humanity soon
and the only existential threat Humanity
faces even more frightening than a than
a nuclear war is global warming going
above 1.5 degrees in the next 20 10
years I've heard young leaders talk with
me about a term they've coined called
climate anxiety
right which is fear of of the future and
the unknown of whether it makes sense
for you to even think about having
children whether it makes sense for you
to think about aspiring to buy a home
because what will this climate be
climate change is the crisis of our
lifetime
we have an obligation to Future
generations to make sure that we have a
planet for them to live on that's what's
boiling the oceans creating these
atmospheric rivers and the rain bombs
and sucking the moisture out of the land
and creating the droughts and melting
the ice
but now the constant climate doomsday
talk is getting some pushback from Bill
Gates of all people the billionaire says
Democrats are full of hot air
there's a lot of climate exaggeration
you know that claimant is not the end of
the planet so the planet's going to be
fine uh we're not going to completely
reverse development so this is all
numbers uh you know will we hit 1.5
degrees no will we hit three degrees no
it will be below we'll be in that range
the lower the better and the you know
the sense of progress that's important
for people to see that emissions in many
areas have come down
climate freaks in the media also love to
exaggerate The Washington Post is
basically calling you a junkie if you
like you to use your air conditioning
when it's hot check out the headline
addicted to cool how the dream of air
conditioning turned into the dark future
of climate change all right judge will
Bill Gates's statement make an impact on
the global warming hysterics no no no
because the people who want us to be
petrified that the world is coming to an
end and I think according to Summit
should already have come to an end uh
they just want to make sure that we
leave live a minimalist life while they
Prosper based upon all the money they
make from the green Energy bill that was
uh touted as the inflation reduction act
and you know while we suffer they don't
want us to have gas stoves they don't
want us to have fans they don't want us
to have gas cars uh and they are just
interested in making sure that we're as
miserable as possible you shouldn't be
eating meat you shouldn't be doing
anything that we're doing but the truth
is it was very interesting reading the
article uh that talked about Gates
Bloomberg as well as there were three of
them uh Prince William and they talked
about the fact that not funding
industries that emit heat trap up and
gas Technology Innovation and it's able
to protect certain things and make sure
there isn't that much in terms of carbon
emission without changing our whole
lifestyle and telling us that we're just
horrible people like if you at some
point they're going to say don't have
kids because they breathe too much air
it's ridiculous Greg my sources at the
Washington Post Newsroom tells me tell
me the thermostat is at 66. do you know
what this this is my theory the author
was a man this was to get in with the
ladies because who complains the most
about how cold it is cold it is it's the
women at work so he's like the White
Knight fighting the office thermostat
and he's throwing Western Civilization
under the bus calling everybody addicts
how much you want to bet
he wrote that story in an
air-conditioned room and if he didn't
then he's a lying sack of poop by the
way I love Kamala uh talking about how
climate hysteria which is pushing is
creating some kind of mental anxiety
among among kids and young people that's
like a shoplifter complaining that
Walgreens has locked up all the
expensive stuff it's a marriage of
culpability and stupidity and how much
you want to bet like like oh now I want
to go to your you said something it was
really surprising you said something
smart uh what were yours
this has been a long time ago you were
talking about when you focus on the
specifics of an issue the left falls
apart so as long as they talk about
something general whether it's air
conditioning or something they can get
away with it but if you ask them
appointed specific question so you have
an elderly grandmother on a hot
sweltering day and she's not remember
people died during heat waves in France
when their doctors were gone you know
it's well well reported she said she's
let's say she's in a rest home in a
sweltering day in August does she not
deserve air conditioning what would how
would he answer that question you know
he would he deny it would he deny it so
I don't know I think that um
it's nice to see all these people coming
out and saying too much but a lot of
damage has been done and they always
blame capitalism for this that was part
of the whole argument here but how do
they explain China and and communism and
the contribution to the climate from
that end I think going after something
that saved lives uh is a little rich in
a world where you can actually point at
obvious things that kill people like say
War right I mean I imagine the Ukraine
war must not be good for the environment
it's definitely not good for the people
these idiots they know what they're
doing when you saw that that clip of
them all sandwiched together it's a cult
but it's a sophisticated cold it's
driven by a I would say a white
combination of virtue signaling and
self-loathing and I think that they need
to live in their own damnations just the
way the uh migrants were were bussed to
these cities somehow they've got to walk
the walk and we have to force them to do
it by going into their home taking their
air conditioning turn off the thermostat
at the Washington Post Newsroom let's
see how productive by the way can one
more Point sure joined by Jeff Bezos who
uses the most air conditioning Amazon
bands dropping off your T-shirt to your
front porch that's true that is a lot of
emissions when it comes to the delivery
trucks super his super yacht is colder
than a morgue that's absolutely true
well it's because he has a lot of dead
bodies oh yeah fun I haven't seen those
on Prime day
um we absolutely need more Innovation
and and we need more ways of taking heat
out of the air because that's what air
conditioning is I watch a lot of This
Old House oh yeah that's that's a recent
development but how do you think you're
going to sell people on this cult if
everything about the cult because
traditionally culture like okay we have
to suffer a little bit here but when we
get there there will be abundance
there's no abundance in this scheme you
can't have kids you got to smell like
stinky Germans who live in
unair-conditioned dwellings you can't
eat what you want you can't go where you
want because we have to end fossil fuels
that means no more driving no more
flying no more Super Yachts but they're
completely on serious because Innovation
comes from capitalism number one and
number two we're not going to do
anything unless we Embrace nuclear
energy if you want clean abundant power
which is how you power civilizations you
have to have a a conversation ongoing
about nuclear energy they don't want to
do it even though the facts and the
evidence damn they're poorly cobbled
together thesis you've praised Bill
Gates on the show many many times
Jessica now that he says this is just a
panic attack and that humans will adapt
and it's not going to be doomsday would
you like to continue your praise or will
you like to change positions it's
actually the first time that one of your
lies I'm okay with because I do like
Bill Gates a lot I don't think I've
praised him many times on the show but I
think he's an incredible innovator and
one of the most exciting Americans that
we've ever had very exciting he what
he's given us he is that exciting and
what he's talking about is moderating
your lifestyle that's the thing you you
pick something up and you run all the
way in the opposite direction with it
like he said you know climate change
isn't real or don't change the way that
you live at all that's not what he's
saying he's saying that the world isn't
going to end by 2028 or whatever it was
that AOC said and Bill Gates gives a ton
of money to fight climate change let's
be clear tens of millions of dollars for
the Bill of Melinda Gates Foundation he
is a climate investment firm called
breakthrough energy he's not someone who
doesn't believe in the fact that man is
making this worse and the air
conditioning guy
again he's not talking about no air
conditioning he's saying if you go to so
I don't know how you keep your house I
like to sleep with it particularly cold
at 67 degrees
what it's nice and cold but on the point
is can you keep your house at 72 degrees
73 degrees and I lived in England for
six years we didn't have air
conditioning at all and I was not an
elderly woman at that time that was
going to at that time
be 40 next year
that'll do it and that was the point of
the piece to just say that there are
people in developed Nations
right this isn't someone that's sweating
it out to it
yes they aspire to take care of the
planet no they aspire to be comfortable
in the summer
weather Americans do but when you go to
if if you go into like a car dealership
in Texas during the summer you don't get
how cold it is in there it's like 62
degrees that's because they all have
nuclear power in their dealerships in
Texas just be moderate in the way you
approach all of this you don't have to
give up meat that's like telling people
what to do
I'm tired of it Jessica someone have a
mirror around
mirror mirror on the wall and by the way
who has the fairest glasses of them
polarized Friday thank you all right
thank you very much yes I really
appreciate it yes in solidarity with
Jesse thank you very much hopefully I
won't have these on Monday ahead please
don't shave your head even the Democrats
are sick of sloppy fettermen after is
dressed down embarrassment hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else